[Musique]
et on ouvre cette page loisir avec vos
idées de sortie Gabriel pour ce weekend
on commence avec un concert qui aura
lieu demain soir à la lanterne de
rambouillé oui tout à fait Mathilde et
àaffiche l'artiste Arthur hache il
présentera notamment son dernier album
intitulé La Vie un album dans lequel on
retrouve la poésie de l'artiste mêlé à
l'énergie du rock et de la pop qui sont
caractéristique pour assurer sa première
partie la chanteuse Lisa Portelli à
l'approche du spectacle nous avons
rencontré l'artiste regarder son
interview
[Musique]
express je suis chanteuse musicienne
avant tout enfin je me considère des
fois plus comme musicienne que comme
chanteuse mais je suis vraiment
chanteuse j'ai sorti cinq albums à la
base je suis guitariste électrique et
mais maintenant mon ma musique est très
électronique aussi euh j'ai été attiré
par par le fait de chanter à travers des
envies de
poésie mais
rock la poésie elle est inhérente à mon
travail je pense que même la poésie
c'est un rapport au monde donc il se il
transpire dans la dans la façon de faire
la musique qui est très particulière
singulière et c'est ça qui me plaît donc
même ma façon de faire de la musique
électronique elle est elle est poétique
au final
parfois même un peu expérimentale et
j'assume complètement mais il y a les
mélodies sont très importantes pour moi
donc et c'est très éteré parfois et et
parfois très très
[Musique]
brut e j'atin l'inge d'or l'innocence
retrouvée tremble en moi la douceur la
chaleur de l'été j'ai longtemps par
couru les vallées
d'infortune tant de prières froides les
Tanis de mes
[Musique]
amertume en première partie d'arthurage
étant donné que je suis en finalisation
de mon prochain album qui s'appelle
absence je vais jouer ces morceaux qui
sont pas encore sortis qui sortent le 8
octobre 2024 absence c'est c'est un
voyage j'ai raconté un voyage en
plusieurs étapes chaque chanson est
l'étape d'un voyage hisoire c'est une
femme qui faire voyage au fond des eos
et qui finit recracher par la mer tout
[Musique]
simplement et pour assister au concert
quelques places sont encore disponibles
sur le site internet de la ville de
Rambouillet la musique à l'honneur ce
weekend Gabriel puisque ce sera
également la nuit des conservatoires oui
l'événement national fait son retour
pour une 11e édition cette année encore
la programmation est gratuite et ouverte
à tous l'objectif célébrer la richesse
et la diversité de nos conservatoires au
travers d'une soirée festive au
programme de la musique sous toutes ses
formes choral orchestre ou encore
représentation théâtrale vous attendent
parmi les villes partenaires trois
villes à Saint-Quentin en iveline il
s'agit de morpas trappe et plaisir qui
vous donne rendez-vous dès 18h le
programme en intégralité est à découvrir
sur le site de vos communes direction
poissie à présent avec une exposition à
découvrir à la maison de fer oui je vous
propose de redécouvrir poissie à travers
la photographie jusqu'au 26 février le
photographe Maxime vistico expose à la
maison de fer de poissis au travers de
ces photos on découvre la cité
Saint-Louis sous un nouveau regard avec
charme et authenticité et la
particularité de cette exposition
Mathilde c'est que tous les clichés ont
été pris à l'argentique ce qui donne ce
côté rétro que vous voyez à l'image
c'est un peu devenu votre lieu culturel
préféré la maison Gabri on poursuit avec
vos idées de loisirs à Versailles un
opéra baroque vous attend durant tout le
weekend oui vendredi samedi et dimanche
l'opéra royale de Versailles accueille
don quiichot chez la duchesse d'après
l'œuvre de favar et Boismortier au fil
d'une intrigue délirante où le héros
croise tour à tour monstre enchanteur ou
encore princesse ce Balet comédie vous
transportera au travers de ses actes
entre danse et cœur décalé et audacieux
un spectacle tout public à découvrir en
famille attention par contre Mathilde il
ne reste plus que quelques places on
termine avec un bon plan une braderie
gratuite ce samedi à guillencours oui
son nom gratiferia le principe de cette
braderie vous l'avez dit vous pouvez
prendre ce don vous avez besoin dans la
limite de trois objets par personne
l'avantage c'est que vous pouvez le
faire complètement gratuitement alors
parmi les objets à découvrir livre
décoration ou encore jouets ou petits
électroménagers une bonne initiative
vous connaissez toujours les bons plans
Gabriel j'aime bien les partager en plus
donc merci beaucoup Gabriel